يقضي عبد الرزاق وقته في التحديق
في السماء ، لقد كان مدرسًا ، لكن في
حياته الأخرى
، أصبح مراقبًا الآن جزءًا من فريق مدرب
على الأرض في جميع أنحاء سوريا
يبلغون عن ملاحظاتهم حول
أنواع الطائرات التي يرونها واتجاهها.
لقد كنت مبتذلة ، أنا محامي ليمون
وتم تعيين APNIC لملء هيا تمرا ،
أوه ، نعم ، إنه مراقب آخر
للملاحظات جنبًا إلى جنب مع معلومات عن
أشياء مثل أنماط الطقس
وبيانات الهجوم التاريخية التي تغذي
خوارزمية تشكل جزءًا من تحذير مبكر
النظام المسمى سينتري بواسطة
أنظمة هالي يصل إلى مستخدميه عبر
التلغرام ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي hala هو من
بنات أفكار الأمريكي جون ييغر
وفريقه ، هذا ليس مفهومًا جديدًا ،
لذا ظهر في الحرب العالمية الأولى والحرب العالمية
الثانية وحتى بعد ذلك الحكومات
مثل المملكة المتحدة  ولنا  استخدمنا استخدام
المدنيين المدربين للعمل كمراقبين للطائرات ،
قمنا للتو بتطبيق ما يقرب من سبعة
عقود من
التقدم التكنولوجي وأعدنا بشكل أساسي
نفس النظام بالضبط ، فما مدى السرعة
من النقطة التي يدخل فيها مراقب
المعلومات إلى تحذير يتم
إنشاؤه بالفعل داخل  بضع ثوانٍ
من تلقينا ملاحظة
ذات درجة عالية من الثقة لدرجة أنها
ستطلق تحذيرًا لبضع ثوان
من الإدخال إلى تنشيط
صفارة الإنذار من الغارات الجوية
ومجتمع فعال في استقبال الهاتف المحمول في سوريا
يمكن أن يكون متقطعًا ولكن AB the  قال
الرجل يوصي halle لعملائه
التناغم هو منطقة anitha حتى بالنسبة لأولئك
الذين لديهم مأوى ، غالبًا ما يكون هذا مؤقتًا
محمد أب صغير لطفل يبلغ من العمر شهرين قام
بحفره لعائلته
وأقاربه ، ليس كثيرًا ولكن كل
ما لديهم هو مدى فعاليته  هل تعتقد
أنك كنت قادرًا على أن تكون في حالة
تمكننا من قياس الخسائر في
موقع يتعرض للقصف الثقيل  منة
قبل وبعد وضع نظامنا في
مكانه وتفعيله ، رأينا انخفاضًا بنسبة تصل إلى
سبعة وعشرين بالمائة في
القدرة المميتة ، يقول جون موظف سابق في وزارة الخارجية ،
إن هلا جاءت على أنها
إدراك
بأن منع القنابل
والعنف بطريقة ما  خيارات
للتخفيف من تأثير القتل العشوائي
ولا يتعلق الأمر فقط بإنقاذ
الأرواح في سوريا ، أعتقد أن العالم
يقضي وقتًا هائلاً في
تركيز الطاقة والموارد على الكثير
من قضايا المصب التي تبدأ
بالعنف ضد المدنيين ،
والنزوح ، والنزوح ، والقضايا الاجتماعية والاقتصادية.
كل شيء يبدأ بقتل الأبرياء
في التمييز إذا كان بإمكاننا المساعدة في
التخفيف من آثار هذا العنف ،
نعتقد أنه يمكن أن يكون لديك تأثير متتالي
ليس فقط لسوريا ولكن لكل
دولة أخرى في العالم
أروى ديمون تعثرت سي إن إن